الوضع في غزة كارثي، كما تعلمون، فقد
قدرت وكالات الأمم المتحدة المختلفة
أن ربع
السكان المدنيين يتضورون جوعا، كما تعلمون أن حوالي 93٪
من الناس في وضع أزمة،
أم أنكم تعلمون كارثة إنسانية سريعة غير مسبوقة
وهي تماما
أحد منتجات الحصار، كما تعلمون، تسمح
الحكومة الإسرائيلية بدخول قطرات قليلة
من المساعدات الإنسانية، ولكن
من الواضح أنها غير كافية على الإطلاق
لسكان حيث تعلم أن
جزءًا كبيرًا منهم
نازحون داخليًا. توقفت التجارة
بسبب القصف، ومن الصعب
القيادة  كما تعلم، تتنقل بالسيارة أو حتى تقوم
بتوصيل المساعدات الإنسانية بسبب
القصف، وإسرائيل تسمح بدخول
القليل من المساعدات، كما تعلم جزئيًا، فهي
تمنعها جزئيًا، فهي تفرض
عقبات بيروقراطية، لكن خلاصة القول هي أنك
تعلم أنها تعاقب
السكان المدنيين في غزة بشكل جماعي  من خلال
حرمانهم من الضروريات الأساسية في
لحظة أزمة حادة، شعرت
بالانزعاج الشديد عندما علمت بالادعاءات القائلة
بأن عشرات من موظفي UNRA
شاركوا أو تواطؤوا في
هجوم حماس القاتل في 7 أكتوبر على
إسرائيل، وبالتالي فإنك تعلم
رد فعل قوي على  هذا مناسب، لست
متأكدًا من أنه كان من الضروري
تعليق المعونة لأن أونرا
تعهد بالفعل بأنه سيصل إلى جوهر
هذا الأمر ويمكنه محاكمة الأشخاص، لذلك تم
اتخاذ الموقف المناسب، كما
تعلمون، القلق بصراحة هو مفارقة
هذا لأنك تعلم أن هناك هذا
الادعاء بأن عشرات من موظفي UNRA
ارتكبوا خطأً خطيرًا ولكنك
تعلم أن هذا كان كافيًا لحمل الولايات المتحدة على
تعليق المساعدات، ولكن بعد ذلك عندما تفعل إسرائيل، كما تعلم،
وجدت
محكمة العدل الدولية للتو أنها تتصرف بشكل
معقول  ترتكب جرائم إبادة جماعية في غزة
في حين أن هناك بالفعل أدلة وفيرة على
أنها ترتكب جرائم حرب واسعة النطاق
من خلال
قصفها العشوائي، وهجماتها غير المتناسبة على
السكان المدنيين، وحرمانها
من الضروريات الأساسية من حيث
المساعدات الإنسانية من هؤلاء
السكان، ولم تكن جرائم الحرب هذه
كافية.  لحمل الولايات المتحدة على تعليق
مساعداتها العسكرية السنوية لإسرائيل البالغة 3.8 مليار دولار أو وقف بيع
الأسلحة لإسرائيل، لذلك هناك القليل من
الانفصال هنا كما تعلم نعم، حيث ارتكبت
حفنة من الموظفين شيئًا خاطئًا
أو على الأقل يُزعم أنهم فعلوا ذلك  لكن إسرائيل
هناك أدلة هائلة على أنها على
أعلى المستويات، من حيث
سياسة الحكومة، ترتكب
جرائم ضخمة في غزة، لكن الولايات المتحدة تحافظ على
تدفق المساعدات. أتمنى لو كان هناك
رد فعل هادئ على ما تفعله إسرائيل
كما حدث بالفعل.  ردًا على هذه
الادعاءات في هذه المرحلة، لست
متأكدًا من أنه كان لها تأثير لأن
القرارات قد تم اتخاذها للتو، أعني
بوضوح كما ذكرت أن
الوضع الإنساني في غزة كارثي، لكن
تعليق المساعدات، كما تعلمون، ليس الأمر
كما لو كان  أونرا تعيش كما
تعلم، أنا متأكد من أن لديهم ما يكفي من المال
لدفع رواتب موظفيهم والحفاظ على
استمرار الإمدادات لفترة من الوقت، لكن
إذا أصبح هذا التعليق طويل الأمد،
فإنه يحول الوضع الكارثي
إلى كارثة أكبر  أتمنى فقط
أن تقوم الولايات المتحدة في قرارها السريع
بتعليق المعونة إلى unra بسبب
مزاعم بارتكاب مخالفات من قبل
حفنة من الموظفين، وأتمنى أن تكون هناك
حساسية مماثلة لتوضيح
المخالفات التي ارتكبتها الحكومة الإسرائيلية على
نطاق أوسع بكثير والتي يتم
دعمها  أقصد ما يصل إلى 3.8 مليار
دولار من المساعدات العسكرية السنوية
وفكرة أن ذلك يستمر دون
انقطاع، ولا يوجد
تعليق على الرغم من جرائم الحرب واسعة النطاق،
على الرغم من
استنتاج محكمة العدل الدولية بوجود إبادة جماعية معقولة
لا واعية